khoảng chiến dở 3 mưu phút của 1.2 năm 2020,
bằng nguyễn thiết hát, sinh 1.7,
được hiện sẽ mấy cho thật sự lê thi hàng mờ,
sinh 1.7 mốt,
cung chung cần thơ,
lưu tông trên đường trên đường đặc,
phương vị thành, tề phố cần thơ,
thì bất ngờ biệm một đối tượng là năng dưới áp sát,
cứ dật tại sạch,
cú dật làm nận nhân lạc tay lấy,
ná xuống phần đường chương vực lại,
và trạm với sế tải khiến bà hát thử vong tại chỗ,
chỉ mờ biệt tương nạc,
lưới tượng bỏ chủng hỏi hiện chương.
Ngay khi nhận được tinh bà phê vụ an,
chỉ sông phải dự đồng hộ về giáp,
lực lượng trức năng đã bắt sử dực kể gây an là buổi vinc an,
sinh 1.7 mươi bài,
chú tải sát giống dường, tình an rằng.
Hẹn có quan công an đang tạm dưới tượng để tiếp tục đuôi trà làm gió,
sử liên nghiêm theo phía định của pháp lột.